hello my name is Alvin and today I'll be
showing you my recipe for lasagna party
right I was obsessed with like shapes of
any kind where there was a circle
whether it was a pan and I loved the
idea of being able to use a bundt ring
without having to make an actual bundt
cake so I was like oh like what kind of
crazy party food can make itself into a
ring I was like what if you put a
lasagna into a bundt ring pan that's
kind of how the idea came about I wanted
to make lasagna into something that was
handheld when it comes to your meat
sauce because this is going to be a
handheld version we don't want it to be
too watery so reduce your sauce more
than normal so you make sure you don't
have like a soupy ton of sauce you
almost want like a pace like consistency
because when it bakes in the oven you
don't want the water to go everywhere so
if you're not sure just keep reducing it
sometimes what I would do is I would
drain off a lot of the excess oil by
putting everything onto a paper towel
and just letting that drain a lot and
then I would use the rest of it inside
so make sure your fillings are nice and
thick not too thin because if they're
too thin they're just gonna go
everywhere the gist of this recipe is
that you need to basically make a
protective shield of cooked lasagna
noodles to make sure that none of the
filling gets out that's the most
important part you want to make sure
that your lasagna noodles are cooked but
not too cooked because if they're mushy
they can break and they won't hold up so
you want them to be almost al dente even
a little under if that's okay when you
are laying them down and fanning them
out into a long shape you want to make
sure that there are no gaps if you have
any sort of gap the filling the ricotta
the meat it might leak out and you don't
want that so if you're not sure just
keep overlaying them make a really a
nice fan pattern I think it looks really
cool too make sure you're overlapping
noodles are nice and tight don't let any
leakage come through another thing that
I love is clean layers so when
assembling the lasagna ring try to make
sure your meat layer is super smooth
you're leveling your lasagna slices and
you're also making the cheese filling
also very smooth because when you want
to cut it at the end you don't want to
just kind of explode everywhere you want
to cut through you want to see these
great alternating layers between meat
sauce ricotta and meat sauce I think it
looks really pretty
it's funny because I was making this by
myself really late at night and I was
like it's just gonna work it was just me
in the studio nobody else and I'd never
made it before by the time I was done it
was like 10 o'clock and the only people
around with the cleaning staff so I
wasn't sure how cool it was so I went up
to them I was like hey like do you think
this is really good one of the guys took
a bite he was like this is awesome so
super super cool and I was like alright
great they liked it I think we got a hit
one other thing that is really important
is that when it is finished baking
please let it cool I cannot stress this
enough because you know if you imagine
lasagna writer that comes out of the
oven it's really bubbly there's a lot of
stuff going on you want that to all
settle and absorb back in so make sure
you let it cool probably at least an
hour when you touch the side of the
bundt pan you want it to be slightly
warm so you can eat it but not cold not
too hot and trust me on this one you'll
enjoy it a lot later
you gotta put that little bowl of
marinara in the center because that's
kind of what seals it together and once
you kind of cut into it anybody can grab
it take a dip and that's pretty much it
you can use whatever meat sauce you want
if you have your own lasagna recipe do
whatever ricotta filling you want do
whatever meat sauce recipe you have just
make sure they're not too watery other
than that it's all up to you you guys
try it I want to see it posted in the
comments send me a picture let me see
how your lasagna ring turned out because
I think it's a really cool thing when
other people make my recipes so I always
love it when I can just see what you
make so yeah let me know send me a
picture we'll see how it goes okay
that's it
that's it for the lasagna
[Music]